I'm Sean Carroll and I'm a theoretical physicist
at the California Institute of Technology
in Pasadena, California.
And I think about how
the laws of physics came to be,
what they are and how they
make the universe that we live in.
So the Big Bang doesn't break
any of the laws of thermodynamics.
The two big ones are
the first law and the second law.
The first law basically says
that energy is conserved.
The second law says that entropy increases,
the disorderliness,
the disorganisation of things increases over
time.
So the Big Bang... we don't know if it
was the beginning of the universe or not.
If the universe has zero energy total,
which is possible,
then the Big Bang could have
been the beginning of the universe.
And it could have been the first
moment in the history of the universe
without violating conservation
of energy because energy is zero.
The second law, the entropy increasing,
is an interesting case
because near the time of the
Big Bang entropy was very, very, very low.
That's why it's been increasing
for the past 14 billion years.
So that doesn't violate the
second law but the question is -
why did the Big Bang have such a low entropy
and the answer there is that nobody knows.
This is an open question for cosmology.
Why was the condition near the Big Bang
so special, so organised?
There are, as you might expect,
many theories and many guesses
as to why
the Big Bang had such a low entropy.
I'm responsible for some of them myself.
For example, maybe before the Big Bang,
maybe there was something before the Big Bang,
and before the Big Bang maybe there was a
condition where the entropy was very, very
high,
but maybe the laws of physics are such
that there is no maximum value for the entropy.
So that no matter how high the entropy gets,
it can always get higher.
And maybe the way it gets higher is by spitting
off a new universe by a quantum transition
that bubbles into existence a whole other
universe
that breaks off from its parent and goes its
own way.
Maybe that's where we came from.
Maybe our Big Bang started tiny and low entropy
because it just pinched off from
a larger, high entropy universe.
If there are many different universes
we don't know what the laws of physics
are going to be like in the other ones.
We have theories of course.
According to some of those theories, the laws
are exactly the same in all the different
universes.
In other models some of the laws are different
but there's still basic principles that are
the same.
So for example the idea of electric charge
might
be slightly different in one universe than
in another.
The charge on one particle or another.
But the idea that charge is conserved
is probably true in all of the different universes.
The idea that energy is conserved is probably
just true no matter what universe you live in.
Well if there are different regions of space
where there are different laws of physics,
apparent laws of physics, what
we call low energy laws of physics,
then probably the boundary between
them would be pretty crystal clear actually.
It's very much like space itself is in a
different phase from one place to another
in the same sense that we
use the phrase "phases of matter".
Ice. Liquid water. Water vapour.
Different phases water can be in.
And you know where the boundary is
between the ice and the liquid water.
In the multiverse it's like different regions
of space are in different phases altogether
and we'll probably be able to know
where the boundary between them lies.
As far as we know there is no necessary way
to be able to observe these other universes
even if they do exist.
Now that's not necessary there's
possible ways to observe them
if we get lucky two universes
can actually bump into each other.
You could actually see this sort of bruise
on our universe when we got bumped into
by another universe at a very, very early
times.
Of course we really don't mean universes at
all.
What we really mean is a region,
an area, of our universe,
that there are different regions that have
different apparent laws of physics.
So this would be like a bubble in a pre-existing
space
and the bubbles grow and
the bubbles can bump into each other.
How would you know?
Well if it happened early on
in the history of our universe,
it could either dump energy into us
or leech energy out of us.
So there'd be a region of our early universe
that was
at a slightly different temperature than the
rest.
Now we have a record of what
the temperature was in our early universe
from the cosmic background radiation,
the leftover radiation from the Big Bang.
So what you do is you look at this cosmic
microwave background radiation and you ask
are the regions, hopefully circular regions,
where the temperature is a little bit different
over all.
Now of course we have done this very, very
carefully.
We've seen nothing. There are tiny variations,
but they do not look like circles,
they don't look like universes bumping into
each other.
So the parameter space for this to be real
is very, very small right now.
I suspect it's not going to happen but we'll
keep looking.
Otherwise we just have to ask -
is this idea of the multiverse
the best way we have of explaining the
universe that we do see and if not, we'll
abandon it.